[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and we
officially have news that Robert Downey
jr. will be returning as Iron Man for
2020s Black Widow if you're confused by
this story don't worry because we're
gonna be breaking it all down in just a
second but if you one of the people that
got dusted during the snap and haven't
for whatever reason seen Avengers
endgame and I highly recommend that you
turn off now we're gonna be discussing
the end of the movie as well as the time
setting for Black Widow so there's gonna
be heavy spoilers here without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Robert Downey jr. is
return for Black Widow okay so a movie
coming out about Black Widow that
features Robert Downey jr. might be
confusing to some as at the end of
Avengers endgame
both he and Black Widow were dead after
having sacrificed themselves in order to
stop danos firstly in case you don't
know Black Widow is actually set between
the events of Captain America Civil War
and Avengers infinity war when both of
the characters were live in kicking so
Widow has just come off the back of
helping Steve escape from the airport
and Ironman is taking the defeat at the
hands of Bucky and cap in his stride
though he did change his name a Tony
stank to hide from the shame hash tag
fan theories anyway this more than makes
the appearance capable without seeming
too jarring the report that comes from
deadline which I think we can all pretty
much agree is legitimate news source
talks about how the news was revealed at
the Saturn Awards last night this was
also the location where the alternate
Iron Man post-credits scene that shows
Nick Fury mentioning the x-men and
spider-man was showcased which I covered
yesterday so definitely check that out
if you haven't and deadline confirmed
that the character would indeed be
returning the Black Widow which due to
its time setting is said to feature many
cameos from the Marvel Universe but
characters who are seemingly long gone
deadline didn't offer up any other
information other than the fact that he
would be in it and it's clear that we
probably won't get much on it as Marvel
will likely want to keep elements of it
a surprise if it's not
the growth I think it probably will be a
cameo and there are some unconcerned
reports that in Marvel's Hall H panel at
comic-con there was a clip of Tony
warning widow that they're coming for
you whilst this was footage from the
original Civil War it could perhaps be
used once more to recontextualize things
and maybe even develop to show more of
that scene now this news is surprising
because Downey did recently say that he
feels like he's got off the Marvel train
at the right time
but in the wake of spider-man no longer
being at Disney perhaps the company are
still trying to have him tied to the
universe just in case their new golden
boy doesn't come back either way the
news is very interesting and I can't
wait to see how the character is
integrated into the film which releases
next year I think Black Widow will have
a few more surprises too so make sure
you stay locked to the channel for all
the news on the character's return as we
get it will be slid I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this report and if
you're excited for the film even more
now comment below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the never-before-seen Iron
Man post-credit scene would you be
linked after this I go over how it could
have massively changed the shape of the
MCU and play the clip as well so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come talk
to me about movies TV shows games and
comic books and you can follow me on
twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just
wanna let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Robert Downey's unions
return in the comments section below the
one will be chosen at random on October
the 15th and the blue row be shipped out
from then to ever get surprised it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
peace
[Music]